hello I'm Hillary and Matthews and today
we're going to talk about Joan of Arc
our story begins in France in the year
1412 the Hundred Years War is raging in
Europe between France and England so
Joan of Arc was a peasant girl she's 13
years old she's in a field then all of a
sudden she hears voices we have a
mission for you and she was like and
they were like I'm Saint Michel I'm st.
Margaret and I'm st. Catherine and
they're like all we want is for you to
go to church and just like be cool and
chill and obedient
she's like that's it and they're like
yeah that's it
the king of France was King Charles the
six people around him get him to sign a
peace treaty that will end the Hundred
Years War he has a son also named
Charles Charles of Valois also called
the Delfin so when his father signed
this peace treaty
it was disinheriting him from the throne
gosh darn it it's just one little drop
it's been happening this whole time okay
so Joan is now a 16 year old girl and a
16 in a 16 year old world and these
voices they're like hey girl you need to
leave France to victory and get Charles
Valois crowned as the rightful king of
she was like you guys does not only you
told me the first time you guys they're
like you need to go to this Lord
gentleman named boat record he's gonna
help you get Charles crowned then she
runs away from home to Lord
boat report she arrives and Jones like
hello I am Joan and I am here because
Saints talked to me in my head and it is
God's will to have Charles of Bell walk
round the rightful king of France and
Lord butter credits straight up like get
this crazy girl back to her home but
like then what happens is that she gets
kind of like a following people have
heard about Joan of Arc and they are on
board
Lord bone record is like okay well
actually we can work with this and Jones
like cut off my hair and dress me in
men's clothes to I don't get raped and
he's like okay because it was really
dangerous because she's a woman oh god
the Middle Ages
I'm glad we're not in them amen too
harsh to women and the breath was bad so
they arrived at Jinyoung and Trust is
not while it's like um week who's here
like a 16 year old girl who hears the
voices of saints and he's like okay you
know what here's what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna put on this big goofy mustache and
this big floppy hat and I'm gonna trick
her and I'm gonna see if she knows
what's up and so he's just like record
ear I'm just a regular old guard ear and
she walks him and she's like your
child's about wow you are my rightful
king he's like wow
slow clap he's slow clap sir can you
believe that he's slow clap sir the
first low clock yeah it was the first
slow clap and so he's like great because
we want the same thing which is for me
to be king of France so Joan was like
okay dude gimme an army
I want that army okie mean an army and
he's like okay guess what army bestowed
she sets out with this army to Orly oh
so they get in there and they were like
okay here's what's up we have to
strategize we have to think about this
logically we have to make plans and Joan
was like no we gotta just go for it you
guys because God wants us to do it and
they're like oh my gosh God yeah he's
the top we are going to just freaking
hate it when people say frickin insane
differently so then they just go for it
and they are like attacking and
attacking and attacking the English and
Jonah's in the thick of it and she is
not shying away and then whoa
she gets hit in the shoulder with an
arrow but here's what's amazing the
English surrender and they're like white
handkerchief white handkerchief you do
hankerchief instead of handkerchief yes
yeah I do okay and everyone's like we
did it and we did it because Joan of Arc
led us to this point
char's about while the deaf man is
crowned King of France and everyone's
like yay then Charles of Valois is like
now I want you to go to Paris and take
Paris so cool I'll do it
so John goes to Paris and she shoots a
bunch of arrows so in the midst of this
battle Joan is captured they're like we
got you oh did we ever get you
you aren't meirin's wins you are wearing
men's clothes and now girlfriend that
means you got to be burned at the stake
she's like Joan of Arc 19 years old is
put onto a wooden stake and then they
light up her
and then she starts calling out for her
Saints and she's like say my god the Big
Kahuna say Michael st. Margaret ok st.
Catherine st. Catherine st. Margaret st.
Catherine that Michaels a marker st.
Catherine
it's like cricket cricket cricket and
everybody's just watching this a 19 year
old woman just get burnt alive at the
stake
so then John she dies the is it
redundant to believe in your own beliefs
I don't care and neither did John here's
the thing about 17 year olds at that
time standing in a field blinking at
this time looking at instagram blinking
Joan of Arc leading an army
I'm not saying you need to aspire to
more but like maybe aspire to more like
maybe lead an army or two
[Music]